we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question about how I would
handle a particular interpersonal
scenario take a listen hi David I had a
question kind of a philosophical
question to ponder about maybe it's if
someone you know an acquaintance who is
a big admirer of yours okay you found
out later that they were rapist and
murderer right how would you respond to
that would you shut them out completely
would you try to you know get get
further details on on exactly what what
they did would you try to understand or
what I'm just I'm curious listen I have
no idea this has never happened to me
before I've never found out that an
acquaintance or friend or something is a
rapist or a murderer and I don't know
what would happen I mean it's I could
give you some answer I could say oh I
would definitely cut them out of my life
I could never have contact with him
again or I could say you know listen I
would try to understand and if it was
far enough in the past at the time when
they were really a different person then
I would I have no idea I think the
details probably would matter my guess
is that there are people in our audience
who listen they're there there must be
people in our audience who are
acquainted with maybe not murderers but
more than likely at least some people in
the audience the audience is big enough
where there's probably people acquainted
with rapists I don't know I'd be curious
to hear from others what it was like
when something like that was revealed I
don't I think that you know this is like
when people say if I was on a plane and
a
did X or Y here's how I would react I
don't think we know until we're in these
situations I think there's so much in
the details and I wouldn't even pretend
to be able to say definitively what it
is that I would do let me know what you
think if you've been in such a situation
I would be interested in hearing from
you we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about something that
is happening within the healthcare field
the healthcare industry that is not
discussed nearly as much as how we pay
for healthcare Medicare for all etc
which is huge burnout among doctors and
nurses I some personal stories actually
to tell about this we will also talk
about a lot of people are going crazy
about this and Joe Rogan tweeted about
it and I tweeted back that I think
people are misunderstanding there's a
bill that's been proposed in
Massachusetts that would ban the word
[ __ ] and people are going crazy about
language policing and all this stuff if
you understand what it is that is going
on you would realize that this is like
nothing that this shouldn't even be a
news story and then lastly a Georgia
sheriff started putting no
trick-or-treating signs in the yards of
sex offenders in advance of Halloween
and the sex offenders are now suing we
will talk about the legal and the social
and the cultural and the logical when it
comes to that story all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show the show
can continue there is more show two ways
to access it become a member at join
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show much
more coming up on the bonus show
otherwise we'll talk to you tomorrow